we'll do the first half and then i'll
respond
the [ __ ] told us women that we should
weigh 120 pounds
women
no
are you [ __ ] serious what in [ __ ]
deflection is this i'll [ __ ] tell you
who capitalism and [ __ ] patriarchy in
the [ __ ] 50s it was you should put on
some weight in [ __ ] 80s and 90s you
should lose some weight in early 2000s
you weren't considered beautiful unless
we could count your [ __ ] ribs the
[ __ ] model industries just started to
accept plus size models industries
controlled by men you're gonna [ __ ]
tell me it's women who set the beauty
standards the [ __ ] audacity
capitalism literally tells people that
they don't look beautiful so they can
sell the [ __ ] cure a product so they
can [ __ ] profit patriarchy is so far
up our asses not only they tell women
how they should look to be beautiful in
order to control their bodies but also
tell them whether or not what they can
do with their bodies like abortions okay
this guy is i mean this is he calls
himself comrade whatever i guess he
considers himself a cop does he seem
happy to you i'm just asking does he
seem like a happy person if you had to
just say yes or no you don't we don't
know him personally maybe he's the
happiest person i know doesn't come off
that way you know i don't maybe it's
just a vibe i'm getting
um
first of all he's wrong for capitalism
you just don't get to blame capitalism
for everything it doesn't work like that
again think about the mind of a liberal
though because this is very on point
liberals blame out they don't blame
within it's this one's fault you're a
bigot you're a racist you're it's all
out right it's not what decision did i
make maybe this wasn't right what
accountability do i have for my actions
it's not a personal responsibility
culture liberalism is not grounded in
that
so
again he's wrong
women first of all judge other women
vigorously all the time oftentimes women
set expectations for themselves based on
other women and the way they'll be
judged by them all it happens all the
time you walk into a room women are
always judging other women i've said
this before they'll spot you know one
heritage and curl part here you see this
piece of hair i got here because i got
these headphones on i guarantee you you
think guys are in the chat going oh jet
no it's some girls like didn't she like
curl that p you know it you know it
girls pick on other girls women pick on
other women in sometimes a horrible way
that's a reality secondly again i'm
going to point this out again to you
because i can't stand when liberals
infantilize women
let's say capitalism capitalism
capitalism had an agenda
and they were going to put these girls
on the covers of magazines and blah blah
blah why do you have to chew and swallow
it
why do you have to chew and swallow it
so just because now women with breast
implant let's say you remember the 80s
right it was the breast implant
period of time a lot of women had breast
implants breast implants were everywhere
does that mean that you can't look at
them and say yeah i'm not going to do
that i'm not into it it's not for me end
of story
of course you can make that decision
what are you a baby are you a little
toddler it's like oh well i'll feel bad
about myself i can't no that's a sign of
weakness accept and own that's a sign of
weakness if you see women on the covers
of magazines that are railfin to the
point where they look like they haven't
eaten in four weeks does that mean you
then go no
no it doesn't you don't have to make
those decisions you don't have to make
those decisions and oftentimes by the
way having come from the performing arts
industry and having grown up in the
fashion industry when i was younger i
will tell you that most of the the
derogatory comments that came to me in
my life were from women in the fashion
industry
i went when i was 15 years old i think
it was i may have told the story
initially when we started the show i
don't remember
i went to a a show
i had been it was like a modeling show i
was short so i wasn't going to do runway
but i was there for commercial i was
very young maybe i was 15 maybe i always
had a bit of a booty that's just my body
it is what it is i love it i embrace it
but it was there and i remember them
telling me i think i weighed like
i mean i'm a little under five five
maybe i was 110 pounds at the time and i
remember them telling me my parents oh
she would need to lose weight that all
came from women women were so critical
they used to sit and it was like i felt
like they had magnifying glasses on me
so don't blame you can't blame all of
this out first of all you can't blame it
on all men
it's not you can't blame it on all women
either but you can't say women support
other women and this is coming from the
patriarch that's nonsense it's nonsense
it's just something that these people do
to prop up this idea that women are
persecuted all the time and it's
infantilizing again because it it
implies they have no autonomy over their
own decisions and no responsibility for
their own choices and decisions and
that's just not a world that's accurate
when you're talking about adult women
these are adults are they not
you want to be treated like an adult
there's all these calls for equality and
this that and yet you can't be treated
like a dolph adult enough where you can
discern a shitty guy versus a menacing
guy come on
that's a problem so which way is it
do are women weak and fragile and unable
to make decisions or are they grown
adults that can handle decisions and
responsible citizens with accountability
which one is it you can't have it both
ways
so
i just think it's funny because this guy
like it's like capital again remember
they vomit out all the words capitalism
patriarchy all this nonsense all the
time
actually get into a debate with somebody
like that and they're going to shrink in
two seconds because essentially what
they're doing is infantilizing grown
adult women and in the name of
protecting them utterly ridiculous if
you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode
right here
[Music]